how about we're on the Fox lot Brian and
I were when we worked for Fox and this
Tesla pulls in and it's all tinted
windows and they've rolled down the
window at Sears and Ford and I go
addabani oh [ __ ] that's [ __ ] any
other Jones like joking around and Brian
I didn't know how big I mean Harrison
Ford Fannie's Brian it's super it never
seemed like this gets super nervous and
there's some excessive writers like this
it gives them a peace sign I've never
seen a grown man give another grown man
a peace sign
here's Sephora like Sam just goes so I
can totally acknowledge the peace line
just keeps on going yo bro you just gave
deuces to [ __ ] Indiana Jones don't do
that
it's so great there's a 4d bubble coming
peace like this
I'll do that up you know I do those good
I do like this really well no this is
kind of like yo like not a way of this
but this this is kind of halt this is
I'm reaching for you I'm reaching for it
and they feel too high it's the Heil
Hitler
you don't want that so you can tell you
man I'm now I'm thinking I give peace
signs to people all the time you do this
all the time like a 14 year old Korea
teenager girl yep exactly
thirteen thirteen year old teenager girl
peace peace out nothing wrong with that
my kid all the time but they do sideways
like this they take pictures they go
like this
that's cute lips out though don't you
like this hand forward this hand
backward well that's what Brian did
Harrison that's me bro but but imagine
running up to here some Florida doing
that freaked him the [ __ ] out I do any
high off his ass right yeah driving that
[ __ ] electric doom buggy it was great
man yeah he's um I wonder what he does
with his spare time other than fly
planes
look can you make that much money and
you're that famous and then you just sit
around what do you do I don't know but
there's there's certain guys at that
level right like he's so famous he's a
whole nother level
but I was thing about last night Dave
[ __ ] when Dave Chappelle walked in and
it was like you know you're around birds
around there's some of the greatest
comics in the world then when Dave
Chappelle walks in
wonder if it's weird for him because I
can feel the room like everyone just
stares at him you know he was in the Oh
R and I was in there before he went on
and there's I mean there wasn't a seat I
mean people are in the hallways there's
just watch him do his thing and he's
just he was up there I don't know an
hour two hours just not really doing a
set just feeling it out oh man that must
be weird at where he's at in life that
he just goes up there and it's like the
everything shuts down for it was a comic
like he's not working out right you're
not saying no he's definitely working
out not that's why we put it out correct
but it's different than if somebody else
like all eyes are on them all the time
non-stop so even him working out it's
funny as [ __ ] you know well he he
handles it remarkably well like the way
he just around people like even though
he's super duper ridiculous famous he
handles it like it's not like it wanders
through but man what people start
grabbing at him and wanting pictures and
[ __ ] it's so embarrassing oh they just
they won't let him talk to people like
save your talk to do them they don't
care if you're in locked in a
conversation about your mom's cancer
they don't care there's your bro I get a
picture sure they freak out just like
this is my time to dress up my Facebook
page and they get there with that can
they be the likes they move in on him
like a [ __ ] hawk it's just it's
embarrassing it's embarrassing don't
respect another person having a
conversation they don't wait like no one
sits around and wait it's like in their
head if they don't grab them right now
they're never gonna get that picture so
it doesn't matter who he's talking to
these I've seen it too like I was
talking to the rock once and this dude
literally slid in between us Jesus and
held his phone up to the rock slid in
between us it just didn't ask he was
taking the picture as he was asking he's
can't make a picture with you and just
like in between us like I'm talking
about what's up man you have a good time
Bubba and then this guy slides in got
the camera like no thought whatsoever
for people's space and what did the rock
do he's probably used to advice
hollowed Cengiz has handled it like a
man